today of course is Juneteenth and Jada
pinkett-smith has dropped a special
edition of red Tabletalk today to
discuss racism in America then this
Sunday Jada turns the spotlight onto her
husband Will Smith and he breaks down do
you feel like you are appreciated as a
father I did not have a good time I'm
gonna have to walk this one off
Jada gets right to wills raw unfiltered
emotions as only a wife of 22 years can
et has this exclusive first look at
Sunday's candid Father's Day edition of
red tabletalk it includes adorable never
seen before home movies of their kids
beautiful makeup but Jaden and Willow
are not around for this conversation
it's just the two of them with no
subject off the table divorce was the
ultimate failure for me will is
referring to his 1995 divorce from first
wife Cherie he says that changed his
approach to fatherhood and marriage we
have found so much happiness in our
union in a way that's very different
than most as they've told et over the
years their marriage is unconventional
Jada calls will her life partner not
husband and they have faced plenty of
tabloid gossip and you're getting
divorced again ring on oh it must be
true basically like oh he has an open
relationship
that's not exactly yet the pact that we
have made to one another is that I will
deliver myself to her happy and she will
deliver herself to me happy in 2018 they
took all that speculation straight to
the table we've never been
Scientologists we've never been swingers
will told et the real reason they make
it work really at the end of the day
it's just not quitting our marriage was
the most difficult grueling and
excruciating thing that we've ever done
taken on in our lives and you know we're
just not quitters
[Music]